ich meine wir hatten gerade den Tag der
Deutschen Einheit und erstaunlich viele
Leute haben zugegeben das hat mich
wirklich überrascht also von Politikern
genauso wie von Journalisten dass wir
selten in diesem Land seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg so gespalten wird also dass
die Spaltung der Gesellschaft selten so
groß war und ich denke der Grund dafür
ist dass wir vollkommen verlernt haben
zu streiten dieses die Möglichkeit zu
streiten setzt natürlich eine gewisse
Zivilisiertheit Urbanität Höflichkeit
also bürgerliche Tugenden voraus aber
wenn man heute die großen Themen der
Politik anschaut Massenmigration aber
natürlich auch die Klimakrise Corona ein
schreckliches Beispiel für mein Problem
mein Thema dann sehen wir das gar nicht
diskutiert wird es wird gar nicht
gestritten sondern die Gegenposition
also die Leute die Abweichen vom
Mainstream der durchgesetzt von der
politischen medialen Elite diese
Gegenposition wird diabolisiert für
dämonisiert das sind dann die bösen das
sind die ewig Gestrigen wenn es gut
läuft die reaktionäre eben letztlich
dann auch die Nazis und dieses dieser
slippery slope dass Sie wenn Sie eine
abweichende Meinung äußern zu
irgendeinem großen bedeutenden Thema sie
dann Abrutschen sehr sehr schnell in der
öffentlichen Wahrnehmung in der
Darstellung in der Öffentlichkeit in
dieses rechtsaußenlager das ist unser
eigentliches Problem denn das bringt die
Menschen die anderes denken und andere
Themen haben und Thesen haben zum
Verstummen und deshalb haben wir
persönlich erlebt dass sie selbst
verstummt sind oder nicht mehr
eingeladen wurden oder nicht mehr
eingeladen natürlich unendlich oft das
ist klar da muss man aber aufpassen dass
man nicht mit persönlicher Gekränktheit
das Thema überfrachtet deshalb will ich
das nicht thematisieren aber der andere
Punkt
Stammgast bei ARD
aber vielleicht liegt es auch an meinem
fortschreitenden Alter dass man nicht
mehr so eingeladen aber ich hatte euch
natürlich
Nominierung ich hatte schon sehr sehr
deutlich den Eindruck vor allen Dingen
was viel interessanter war ich habe mir
nebenbei immer auch ein bisschen Geld
verdient bei Veranstaltungen in der
Wirtschaft und mit dem ersten Wort dass
ich gegen Merkels Migrationspolitik
geäußert habe ist das abgebrochen von
heute auf morgen also es kam überhaupt
keine Einladung mehr und das hat mich
nicht besonders
geschmerzt Alter wird aber es war
deutlich ähnlich wie bei ARD und ZDF da
kam plötzlich gar nichts mehr und da
hatte ich schon sehr deutlich den
Eindruck hey wenn du dich da deutlich
artikuliert passiert das und das und
vielleicht nur noch eine Ergänzung dazu
die Leute haben dann auch festgestellt
die mein Twitter-Account mal überprüft
haben und so ich hätte mich in den
letzten Jahren radikalisiert und diese
Radikalisierung hat natürlich auch ein
ganz simplen Hintergrund nämlich ich
wurde pensioniert und nicht die
Pensionierung war ich plötzlich
unangreifbar und konnte sagen was ich
wirklich denke ich habe also gar nicht
anders gedacht als früher
ich war auch lange an der Uni und viele
Professoren die sind kritisch hinter den
Kulissen aber es ist so eine
Hinterzimmer Offenheit aber die Kamera
geht vorbei ich habe das selbst schon
nicht in Deutschland
mit dem ehemaligen bayerischen
Innenminister Hermann über Kriminalität
Ausländer gibt es da Zusammenhänge
natürlich gibt es statistisch
nachgewiesen vor der Sendung hat er
Vollgas gegeben dann ging die Kamera an
und auf Sendung weiter weg hat das
Gegenteil von dem erzählt was vor und
das finde ich schon meine politische
Politiker das er tun könnte
bestimmte Verortung in der Politik das
verstehe ich nicht man wählt ja
Politiker für ihre Meinung die müssen
Kante geben und nicht für einen nicht
meine oder eine schwankende Meinung
werden
ganz schlimm ich meine sie haben das
auch erlebt ich habe zum Silvester ein
Video veröffent Corona haben sie
angesprochen was ganz krass war diese
extreme Mainstream und hatte der Chef
von Ringe Schweiz marc falder hat ein
Video im Geheimen gemacht vor einer
Wirtschaftselite und ich habe das dann
gelegt und dann sagt eben dass er alle
Redaktionen weltweit von Ringe
angewiesen habe regierungstreu zu
berichten jetzt müssen wir vorstellen
das sind Verschwörungstheoretiker die
serioten da die das Gefühl haben das ist
gesteuert von oben jetzt sagt der
mächtigste medienpost in der Schweiz
international tätig eben das nur müsse
Regierungs treu sein und hatten sogar
Bild angegriffen dass ein Link jetzt so
zu Ihnen hier hat Bild danke für Design
aber schon ganz radikal Design sogar
kritisch oder also kritisch sein ist
nicht mehr erlaubt es wird von oben
durchgedeckt das ist ein extremes
Beispiel
viel schlechter als Deutschland hier
muss ich eine Lanze schon da für den
deutschen Medien Journalisten genau
Pandemie muss sagen wir haben kein
Blattform und genommen aber auch
Alexander Kister der oft zu Gast ist von
der Endziffern
musste sie entschuldigen bei Bild das
ist ja attackiert hat aber das ist nur
ein Klaus das Beispiel es gibt auch die
Scheren im Kopf das erlebe ich sehr
stark als das Auto ist journalistisch
trauen das zu schreiben und dann
hinterher oder wir haben immer gesagt
früher bei der Weltwoche wo ich lange
sterben Tag zu machen wir bringen die
Themen alle rümpfen die Nase oder halten
sich die Nase zu ah ganz schlimm und
zwei Jahre später kommt als NZZ mit dem
seitenfular und schreibt das gleiche
also es braucht immer eine gewisse Zeit
du musst einfach den Mut haben die
Meinung zu vertreten aber die Frage aber
die kleine Korrektur die ich gerne
anbringen würde an ihren Beobachtung die
ich sonst 100%ig unterstreiche gerade
als ich das erwähnt habe mit der
Pensionierung und der Freiheit des
Alters wenn Sie sowohl der freien
Meinung die man dann äußern kann ist mir
eines klar geworden wäre ich in dem
Augenblick nicht 65 gerade gewesen
sondern 35 hätte ich dann dasselbe
getwittert hätte ich dasselbe
geschrieben schon gesagt jetzt und ich
verstehe jeden
Assistenten jeden Menschen der am Anfang
seiner wissenschaftlichen Karriere ist
so wie ich mittlerweile auch viele
Journalisten verstehe nicht Politiker da
gebe ich Ihnen Recht aber bei den
Journalisten und Wissenschaftlern die
noch jung sind am Anfang ihrer Karriere
und die im Grunde merken dass sie mit
einem falschen Wort und zu starken
Formulierung
setzen bei denen kann ich das sehr gut
verstehen und ich wäre ich will mir
nicht es ist eine Frage des Mutes da
haben sie recht aber wenn jemand eine
Familie zu ernähren hat wenn jemand
tatsächlich noch nicht gesichert ins ist
in seiner Karriere und seine Existenz
kann ich verstehen dass sie wenigstens
still sind und klein bei geben
schlimm ist es nur dass und das bei den
Politikern in der Tat der Fall dass bei
Leuten die eigentlich von Berufswegen
eigentlich ihre Meinung sein wenn die
genauso pushen wie
reinholen und natürlich mit der Frage es
wurde jetzt gerade schon gesagt bei
Politikern ist es Verständnis sehr
gering wenn man vor der Talkshow den
starken Mann macht und dann in der Talk
so leise ist habe ich auch schon mal
erlebt aber was ich sie fragen möchte
wie sehen Sie das denn in der Politik
sagt jeder was er denkt nein viele
Stimmen ja auch im Namen der Partei ab
also nur für die Parteien großes Problem
und damit habe ich am Anfang ein großes
Problem gehabt das schöne ist ich bin
seit 36 Jahren selbstständig bin völlig
unabhängig und kann so reden wie mir der
Schnabel gewachsen ist und habe immer
eine Folge immer man inneren Kompass das
ist ganz wichtig der ist der konservativ
und da macht man sich natürlich bei
bestimmten Herrschaften keine Freude das
heißt die große Spitzenpolitik bleibt
ihnen dadurch auch verwehrt Minister
wird man so richtig so so ist es auch
der der Listenplatz ja der war voll ich
bin das bewerbe mich jetzt zum zweiten
Mal beim ersten Mal lade ich Platz 51
haben mir gesagt wenn du erstmal einmal
drin bist dann kommst du weiter nach
vorne jetzt bin ich auf Platz 61
nein das ist aber so aber das muss jeder
für sich selbst klären also ich könnte
so nicht ich habe sehr schleimt sich am
besten nach oben in der Politik kann man
das so platt sagen es gibt auch wirklich
richtig gute die auch ihren Weg gehen
auch die jungen Leute die wir bei uns
gerade haben die haben echt eine ganz
klasse Einstellung und machen das selbst
ich habe oft gesagt dass ich das lieber
sagen nein ähm weil es gibt ja
unangenehme Themen da muss noch klare
Farbe bekennen aber für mich ist es ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt dass man
authentisch ist und dann läuft sie auch
eigentlich ne das haben wir zu wenig
gesagt das Klima dass sie beschreiben
ist ja auch sehr gefährlich in unserer
System Auseinandersetzung mit China ich
möchte das überhaupt nicht gleichsetzen
also hier wenn die Leute nicht ins
Gefängnis gehen gesperrt jahrelang und
auch keine vollständige Zensur des
Internets oder sowas natürlich ist das
nicht vergleichbar nur es sollte ja
gerade die Stärke unseres Systems sein
dass sie auch ausstrahlen soll dass man
sagt bei uns kann man auch radikal
unterschiedliche Meinungen vertreten so
die Idee der Aufklärung auch wenn du die
völlig gegensätzliche Meinung von mir
was ich trete dafür ein dass du deine
Meinung sagen kannst und das hat ja
unser System stark gemacht im Vergleich
zu China wenn dieser Vorteil aber nicht
mehr da ist oder zumindest nicht mehr so
offenkundig da ist ist das für uns auch
ein großes Problem in der
Auseinandersetzung aber hier kommt ja
immer dass das Argument kommt ja immer
hier da noch einmal zu ihnen herbolz das
Argument kommt ja immer man kann seine
Meinung sagen wie man will da muss man
aber mit Widerspruch rechnen Michelle
Friedmann hat es letztens ganz groß
erzählt groß getönt jeder kann seine
Meinung sagen den Widerspruch muss man
aber ertragen was würden Sie denn diesem
Gegenargument was ja immer kommt
entgegnen das ist sehr sehr einfach man
muss nicht nur Widerspruch ertragen das
würde ja jeder gerne das wäre ja Streit
so wie wir ihn brauchen Argumente
bringen Thesen bringen Antithesen
Widerspruch das ertragen und diskutieren
aber das ist ja nicht das was passiert
sie kriegen nicht Widerspruch sondern
sie werden gecancelt sie werden
ausgeschlossen sie gehören nicht mehr
dazu sie werden auch an einem
medienpranger gestellt sie sind ein
Außenseiter in Outcast das klassische
Beispiel bei uns in Deutschland ist der
Sarrazin ja also wenn man ein
klassisches Gegenargument genau in
diesem Sinne von Friedmann guckt euch
doch Sarrazin an diese der hat also
Millionen macht der mit seinen
riesengroßen Auflagen der ist Nummer
eins im Spiegel und und und und aber was
ist der defacto der Fall er ist ein
Outcast es ist jemand der Polizeischutz
braucht wenn er auftritt das heißt er
wird der gehört nicht mehr zur guten
Gesellschaft in Deutschland und das ist
ein Preis der gigantisch groß ist und
wenn sie nicht so berühmt sind wie
Sarrazin dann bleibt Ihnen im Grunde nur
die Tatsache dass sie exkommuniziert
sind aus der Gemeinschaft der guten und
das ist das Schlimmste was einem in
einer Gesellschaft passieren kann wenn
sie nicht mehr dazu ausgeschlossen
werden
die Aufklärung angesprochen oder es ist
eine Dialektik der Aufklärung die
Aufklärung kippt in der Gegenteil es
sind ja die besonders tolerant die die
von sich denken sie sei ein tolerant die
dann besonders intolerant sind haben die
Akademie angesprochen die Universität
dass ich verstehe es auch dort nicht
also es gibt keinen grundfreien
Professor das nicht seinem Heilung sagt
und da habe ich das ganz stark erlebt
oder schlimm ist dann für mich wenn
diese Milieu übergreifen die
intellektuelle Kaste sind ob das
Journalisten sind oder Professoren oder
politische gemäß sind die sind alle im
gleichen Mühle aufgewachsen und die
haben dann die gleichen Thesen und dass
das verstehe ich einfach nicht dass man
da nicht Freude hat und
Auseinandersetzung und es wirklich so
die ja die die toleranten die die Links
toleranten die sind dann die die kann
ganz stark mit dem Maulkörben kommen und
da kommt eben die Schere im Kopf die ich
angesprochen habe ich meine unglaublich
oder ein schöner Kinderfilm ein schönes
Kinderbuch und da kommt irgendeine
Spinner These von der kleinen Ecke und
das machten Verlag er sagt wir ziehen
die Bücher zurück es ist quasi selbst
Zensur das finde ich unglaublichen
Vorgang und das wird aber noch lange
erklärt oder gibt es auch die die
kulturelle Aneignung da gab es in der
Schweiz zwei Fälle die wurden dann
europaweit auch diskutiert da waren
weiße Musiker die haben Reggae Musik
gespielt mit Dreadlocks und dann wurde
gesagt Konzert abgebrochen das ist cool
gegangen also da haben wir wirklich fast
alle die den berichtet das geht eben
man heult ein bisschen auf wenn sie auf
der Straße Umfrage machen wie eine zu
verbieten ich habe meine columen darüber
geschrieben ich habe
gehört du hast eine riesen wenn sie
Bevölkerung Frage ich bin überzeugt 99%
der Bevölkerung wird sagen die Spinnen
logisch wie Natur lesen aber es setzt
sich trotzdem in diesen Kreis neben die
Ton angeben sind durch es kommt beim
Start immer mehr es kommt bei den
Verlagen es kommt Bezeichnungen wir
bleiben noch einmal bei dem Beispiel mit
der cancel culture weil sie haben Recht
Winnetou da hat mein Herz auch geweint
aber wenn Menschen werden ist noch ein
bisschen schlimmer als Winnetou wenn er
gekänzelt wird aber da eine Frage an Sie
selbst die unpolitische schauspielerin
Jennifer anist die sich eigentlich
wirklich nicht politisch äußert hat hat
ein großes Interview gegeben vor kurzem
dass sie die cancel culture Ängste da
ist vorne sie ja überhaupt nicht
betroffen aber davon sind Männer in
ihrer Branche betroffen mir tun und so
weiter was ich mich frage wie weit sind
wir denn schon in Deutschland bei in
Amerika ist es ja im Vergleich schon
viel größer die keine
gesellschaftlichen Auswirkungen auf uns
werden wir noch mehr steigen in der
kennzahlsche wird zurückgehen wie
prognostizieren sie es für Deutschland
das ist sehr schwer zu prognostizieren
weil ich natürlich noch nicht bereit bin
zu sagen wie immer machen wir alles mit
zehn Jahren Verzögerung nach was die
Amerikaner vormachen sie haben
vollkommen recht der Zustand in Amerika
auch in England ist noch viel viel
schlimmer als bei uns trotzdem muss man
die walkness als eine sehr sehr
gefährliche kulturrevolutionäre Bewegung
begreifen ich kann Ihnen aber ganz kurz
erklären warum es so ist dass obwohl
viele nicht nur in den Medien auch
Politiker das absurd finden auch gegen
das Gendern sind also über 70% der
Bevölkerung ist gegen das Gendern viele
Politiker sind dagegen warum wird es
trotzdem gemacht und trotzdem
durchgesetzt oder solche Verrücktheiten
wie kulturelle Aneignung das ist ganz
einfach sie können sich klar machen bei
einem normalen wie soll man seine
Einladung zum Essen wo man damit rechnen
muss dass Veganer dabei sind wenn die
wenn die dabei sind dann ist es einfach
eine Lebensklugheit zu sagen ach dann
lasst uns doch alles vegan machen denn
wenn sie etwas nicht veganes anbieten
gibt es einen riesenprozess der Veganer
die ganz wenige sind aber dem Protest
ist riesengroß während alle anderen die
wenn Sie so wollen noch normal essen
dann sagen wir ja gut macht nichts essen
war halt mal vegan kann nichts hören und
genauso ist es bei allen anderen wenn
sie Winnetou rausnehmen aus dem Programm
dann ersparen Sie sich die die
Wutattacken die hassattacken der
Aktivisten der wirken Aktivisten und die
anderen denken zwar sind die verrückt
aber kaufen trotzdem bei dem Verlag die
anderen Bücher weiter also das ist
einfach nur eine Kalkül taktisches
Kalkül zu sagen wie mache ich mir
möglichst wenig
Ärger mit diesen Aktivisten